Por que que tá brigando com coleguinha
hein vocês são amigos vão lá pra casa
direto agora tu vem procurar conversa
com meu Jared um menino tão bom meu
filho não merece essas coisas a mãe do
po não Ela briga pelo filho porque ela
ama o filho acima de tudo ela ama seus
filhos com certeza mas ela sabe que o
filho dela não é nenhum angin não então
ela cai para cima e diz assim ó quem foi
que deu autoridade PR você bater no meu
filho você é mãe dele para bater no meu
filho você é mãe dele por acaso para
bater no gon caramba quando você for Pai
você pode bater nos seus filhos mas no
meu filho você não bate não cala sua
boca G Cala sua sua boca que quando
chegar em casa você vai ver seu [__]
onde foi que tu já viu bater no onde foi
para quando eu tiver falando contigo tu
não me tira paciência que eu te bato no
meio dos teus amigos aqui